We've all got our own reasons for
wanting a doorbell camera.
>> [music]
>> Great, now none of us can WATCH TV.
>> THAT'S MY TV!
>> BUT WHICH ONE SHOULD you get? Are you
going to end up paying a bunch of money
for the hardware, going through the
hassle of mounting and installing the
thing, and only then realize that the
stupid thing turns into a pumpkin the
moment your credit card strikes
midnight?
>> [music]
>> Well, you could do that. Or, you could
let me pay over $2,000
on what we're calling the search for the
perfect doorbell. Okay, not the
catchiest movie title, but if the
indecipherable Spider-Man naming scheme
can net 2 billion a pop, I think we can
make this work. We bought
obtained 13 options from budget to
buzzonkers, mounted them to this
comically wide doorbell frame, and then
let them rip on the driveway at the Tech
House, capturing the comings and goings
of various cars, animals, and people
throughout the day and night. We've
sorted them into budget buckets
according to their upfront cost, and now
we're going to rank them according to
their features, image quality, and their
value over a 5-year ownership span.
Spoiler alert, some of the cheapest
options end up being a lot more
expensive in the longer term. That's how
they get you. And here's how I get you,
with the segue to our sponsor.
>> [music]
[singing]
>> We have a lot of video doorbells to get
through. So, let's quickly run through
what they have in common. They are
mostly all battery operated, aside from
the Ubiquiti's offerings. One is wired
and the other is PoE, meaning that it is
powered over its network cable. And
that's about it. [music] There's a
shocking amount of diversity in
features, even among our budget options
that start at just $10 for the Orbitel
M52. That is a very low price, which is
why they require a subscription if you
want any more than a push notification
for
well,
pushes. If you want live video, though,
that's [music] going to cost you. You'll
have to buy a cloud storage
subscription. The image quality is okay,
though, and their subscription is
reasonably affordable, which pushes it
from, let's say, F all the way up to
a high D tier. But, let's say for a
moment that you had the budget for four
Orbitels. The Arlo video doorbell,
unfortunately, continues its same
mandatory subscription trend, this time
offering only live video until you fork
out some dough. So, no push
notifications. Also, it doesn't even
come with a wall plug so that you can
hear the chime from a common area inside
your home. But, its AI detection was
pretty solid, both recognizing our
fabricator as a person and identifying
our environment as a workshop. [music]
For reference, our next doorbell clocked
that same situation as a pet at the
front door. Interesting. I never saw
Justin that way. Button feel is fine, I
guess, and so is the image quality,
which had this cruising into a C until I
saw the 5-year cost of ownership.
Over $500?
Have you gone mad, Arlo? Low D for low
D. What are you guys doing? Next up, we
finally have our first non-subscription
bell. It also adds some features that we
haven't seen yet, like two cameras, one
pointing down, as well as a whole 32
gigs of onboard storage. So, you got
recording, live view, an included chime,
and two-way voice calls through the app
with no subscription. It's got a little
screen to display canned messages, and
even the image quality is decent. So, uh
question for me, why did I give it only
a B? As crazy as it sounds, it's partly
because of the lack of a subscription.
>> Bro, what are you talking about, man?
>> I cannot buy cloud storage, meaning that
my record of a home invasion, for
instance, can be destroyed by said home
invader with a simple hammer.
Also, the UI/UX was among the worst that
we encountered. Still though, it gets
our coveted Value King award for being
the least expensive viable product over
5 years of ownership. As for the Blink
Doorbell 2K Plus, this one started off
on a pretty rough note. Without the
additional sync module, this thing is
just a brick, just sounding pretty
dangerously close to F-tier product
design. But, the module costs just $20
more and supports multiple Blink
products, and the battery on the
doorbell supposedly lasts up to 2 years.
That sounds kind of perfect if you're
looking for something with the same
pedigree as Ring, but more
wallet-friendly with two-way voice and
live video included. But, there's a
catch. Of course, there is. Recordings
are paywalled, and with image quality
that's only slightly better than the
Havion, let's go with
C minus. Now, it's time to look at our
mid-tier offerings, starting with the
original, as seen on Shark Tank, the
Ring Doorbell. When it comes to ease of
setup, it is clearly the industry
standard for a reason. It was as easy as
putting in a Wi-Fi password, and
everything else happened automatically.
However, that's where the
user-friendliness ended. Amazon acquired
Ring back in 2018, [music] and come on,
guys, they got to get their billion
dollars back somehow. So, this doorbell
app has ads around every corner, and it
even has a store.
Also,
that noise has got to be the most
annoying noise in the world. As for the
image quality, man, I feel like
everything's getting kind of good enough
now that I'm going to need to see them
side by side. So, we'll take a look at
that later. I'm going to give this a
placeholder C tier for the $350 5-year
ownership cost, but who knows? Maybe the
image quality will bump it up. Up
against the Ring is the eufy C31. We
know them for their vacuums, and now we
can evaluate them for their doorbells,
which they advertise as probably the
best for under $100. I do take slight
issue with that because it was listed
for exactly $100, not under $100. But,
there's been no subscription fee for
their core features ever since their
debut back in 2019, which has helped
them build a cult following. If you want
cloud backups, they do offer that at a
pretty average price, meaning that if
this button's any good,
not bad. This might be our first
This might be our first A.
However,
>> [clears throat]
>> it's an A plus.
No, not a high A. I meant A plus some
pretty sketchy baggage. A couple of
years back, eufy had a scandal around
easy public access to unsecured [music]
cameras. And instead of engaging in good
faith, they deflected and obfuscated to
the point where we actually put them in
our sponsor doghouse until at least
2027. With that said, they claim to have
cleaned up their act and have managed to
stay out of the headlines lately. So,
hopefully they'll be back soon enough.
Next up is another no subscription bell
that's priced right in line with Ring,
an offering from TP-Link, the Tapo 2K
Plus. Like eufy, highlights their
internal storage as a key feature,
except they draw the line at 512 gigs
instead of just 128. That is a lot of
clips of your courier delivering your
durable True Spec cables from
lttstore.com than a porch pirate, taking
your cables from lttstore.com.
Then your wonderful SO bringing over
some replacements to help you feel
better. Replacements from lttstore.com.
Build quality for this one is a bit of a
low light though. So, for the same
price, it's hard to give this quite the
same rating. We're going to go with
um
>> [music]
>> B tier.
There you go, Tapo. Next, we have the
doorbell light from Ubiquiti. Like the
others in this price segment, it offers
two-way audio, but it's a little
different as it's PoE. So, you actually
get much more reliable streaming over a
wire. And after the hassle of running
said wire once, you never change a
battery again. However, even though it's
only $100, it requires a whole ecosystem
of products to support it that we're
going to talk about a little bit more
later once we get to Ubiquiti's flagship
offering. For now, I'm going to throw it
in the B tier. There you go, Ubiquiti.
Our last bell in this segment is another
dual camera, this time from Wyze. And
it's going to cost you $20 more than the
rest of the offerings. Why? Well, I
guess part of it could be the second
camera, but the more interesting feature
for me is that this is the first we've
seen to support both 2.4 GHz and 5 GHz
Wi-Fi. That means more consistent video
streaming and lower likelihood of
network dropouts from my personal
experience. It doesn't come with any
built-in storage, but it does support up
to 256 gigs via microSD with no core
features locked behind a paywall and the
option for a reasonably priced cloud
backup. The button
feels pretty nice. I'm putting this in
the A+ tier. Again though, I'm doing the
same bit. A plus some baggage. Wyze has
also made headlines for undesirable
reasons. And actually, that reminds me.
We never even mentioned Ring's recent
collaborations with law enforcement. I
mean, is it possible that cameras on all
the things, surveillance products, are
just magnets for this kind of
controversy? No, it's the children who
are wrong. Let's take a look at their
image quality. All right, Ring.
Got to give you credit. That looks
really nice, but
I think a lot of it is just kind of like
misleading. [music]
It's just the contrast. The eufy
actually has better readability of the
text down the driveway. Meanwhile, the
Tapo is
pretty rough. Ubiquiti is not as good as
I thought. Wow, really?
eufy pulling out the win with Wyze in
second place. Well, isn't that
fascinating? Dynamic range on the eufy
is pretty rough.
I think that could push Wyze into first
place for me. Wow.
All right.
Move you up a little bit.
You, too.
There.
All right. you, Ring.
I'm happy with that. Let's move on to
the flagships now. I'm talking doorbells
that cost anywhere from $150 to $300.
Up first here is eufy again. For an
extra 50 bucks over the last one, we're
getting both 8 gigs of non-removable
storage and a dual camera setup.
However, this one doesn't have
traditional expandable storage. Instead,
it integrates into eufy's homebase
ecosystem for up to 16 terabytes of
additional space. There are cases where
additional controller hardware and
network attached storage does make
sense, but I'll leave it up to you to
decide if this is one of those cases.
Either way, I've got to give it a B tier
placement for retaining most of the key
features on the friendly side of [music]
the paywall. Boop. Next up, we've got
Google's one and only doorbell. It has
the most flat modern design of the bunch
and it's going to cost you 180 bucks and
that's before the $100 [snorts]
annual subscription fee.
It's not all bad news, though, since
they don't paywall recording, live view,
or two-way audio. So,
uh
maybe B tier?
Ooh, only 3 hours of recording history,
and a 5-year subscription is going to
cost me almost $700?
Sorry, Google, best I can do is a C+.
That's just too expensive. Not to
mention it has the lowest resolution in
this price range. Swinging back to the
market leader, Ring. This time, it's
their more premium battery doorbell Pro.
It looks very similar, but the Pro badge
comes with a $150
upcharge. The main difference, a
quick-release battery.
Okay. And a resolution bump from 1080p
to 1536p HD Plus. Otherwise, the
subscription and everything else remains
the same. So,
C at best. I mean, same ease of use, but
also $500 for 5 years of ownership?
Yeah. Finally, we've got the This was
the one made for Linus option, which
comes from, you guessed it, Ubiquiti. I
hate batteries, and the G4 doorbell Pro
uses either the included power
kit/transformer combo, or USB-C, or with
a separate model, you can actually power
it with PoE, just like the doorbell
light. This specific one, though, uses
Wi-Fi for data, but at 5 GHz, so at
least it has that going for it. And
Ubiquiti products are proudly
subscription free. With that said, they
are expensive, and it's kind of hard to
justify the additional hardware that you
will also need, unless you were already
planning to use their ecosystem for
other aspects of your buildout, like
wireless access points. The UI/UX
[music] is getting pretty good, though,
and constantly getting better, and so is
the product line. Ubiquiti pointed out
to us that this particular model is
actually being phased out for something
new that's being developed for Q4 2026.
So, I don't know. Asterisk
tier. High-quality product that costs
the same 10 years later as it does up
front, but it it is really, really
expensive. Now, let's look at image
quality for these premium options and
see if we're going to move anything
around. How about Google? I mean, Google
knows image quality, right? They got the
Pixel.
>> Google one has the lowest res camera and
you could kind of tell.
>> Yeah, like dude, you can barely even
tell that this [music] fence has
vertical slats on some of the panels
that Look at this.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> There's just There's not a lot of
resolution there.
>> It's cartoon.
>> And the You know what? The ring is
honestly not much better. Okay, Eufy
though.
Oh, that dynamic range, Eufy. Eufy, the
dynamic range. They all just kind of
suck. I think the takeaway here is that
I would not pay the extra for a more
premium doorbell camera because all the
cameras are just some flavor of suck.
Recapping then in our budget category,
the Havrion D1 is a clear winner. It's
$79
all-in and yeah, it's got a slightly
unintuitive design and some software
quirks, but for the price and with no
subscription, it's pretty hard to find
fault here. Moving on to our mainstream
options, Wyze looks like a wise way to
go, at least from a financial standpoint
with our 5-year cost of ownership
running us the lowest at $270.
But with that said, it doesn't come with
an SD card, so it's about on par with
both Eufy and Tapo in that regard. With
all three of them falling significantly
behind Ring in terms of total cost of
ownership. Given that all of these
players have had a security scandal in
the past at some point, it feels a
little bit pick your poison and then
Ubiquiti's in there just kind of
uniquely being Ubiquiti with an
affordable upfront price for the
doorbell, but of course all of the extra
baggage that it carries. Finally, for
the flagships, these are a bit tough to
recommend because they don't really do
more than the cheaper options we've
looked at with the exception of Ubiquiti
who has a very fully featured product
here with no subscriptions,
>> [music]
>> as far as we can tell, ever. And if I'm
spending more, then I want it to be in
order to own my data and not have it
used without my permission by Big
Brother or by anyone else. So, Ubiquiti
gets my coveted attaboy of product
design, meaning that uh all that's left
is to say attaboy
to our sponsor.
>> Earn XP, level up, unlock achievements,
and complete quests in the hot new
phenomenon sweeping the nation. It's
boot.dev,
the best way to learn to code in Python,
Go, [music] and more, because it's fun.
Get hands-on building real projects,
track your progress, and rally the
community in challenging BI-MONTHLY
[screaming] BOSS FIGHTS.
All while learning real skills that
could get you a high-paying job. Back it
Oh.
>> Look what the dork squad is up to.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, learning to code, oh, having fun.
Losers.
>> Travis, go away.
>> How's Travis doing?
>> Go away. We're learning valuable life
skills right now, Travis. Travis.
>> Just think about that.
You
You're not going to do anything with us.
Cody.
>> Hey.
Hey, stupid.
>> He is stupid.
>> Yeah. Man, like you, dude. Your mom
makes the worst
YOUR DAD? HE'S LIKE
DUDE, YOUR DOG? Your dog LOOKS LIKE A
HOT DOG. I'd put ketchup on him AND EAT
HIM. WHAT ARE YOU EVEN DOING HERE?
YOU'LL NEVER KNOW BOOTS LIKE I DO.
>> YEAH, DON'T LISTEN TO TRAVIS. Use code
LTT to get 25% off your first month or
year with boot.dev.
>> [music]
>> If you guys enjoyed this video and
you're on the hunt for more video
peripherals, why not check out the time
that we spent two grand trying all the
best webcams? There were a lot of them.
Surprisingly, more even than this lineup
in front of me.